hey 42 here do you write cursive Lee
with beautifully flowing looped letters
or do you print actually a more pressing
question would be do you write at all
can you remember the last time you put
pen to paper instead of finger to
keyboard don't worry you're not alone
the statistics show that every year more
and more people are rapidly foregoing
penmanship altogether in favor of typing
even for small written tasks such as
shopping lists or reminders on sticky
notes most of us have replaced these
with apps a recent British survey found
that one-third of adults hadn't written
anything by hand in the past six months
I - I'm dangerously close to counting
myself amongst their number but I think
that's a great shame furthermore this
trend is damaging to our intelligence as
a species as you will soon find out the
humble pen the great bastion of written
communication for over 5,000 years the
Sumerians created the first written
communication in 3200 BC in Mesopotamia
when they carved out cuneiform script
into stone the foundations of Western
freedoms Magna Carta was inked into
sheepskin with beautiful Latin cursive
at Runnymede in 1215 then in 1776 the
Declaration of Independence was signed
written in a 17th century script called
English round hand which was then mostly
superseded in the late 19th century by
Spencerian script you will have seen
Spencerian script if you have ever seen
what one could argue is a rather popular
logo this handwriting is a deep part of
our culture but today there is a
concerted yet contentious effort by
schools worldwide to move children away
from the pen and in front of computer
screens or in front of tablets tapping
away like little lemmings the logic
behind this is that these devices are
what they will be using
the workplace anyway so why get them
accustomed to an antiquated writing
system that maybe if little to no use to
their career well I'll tell you why have
you ever been amongst a large crowd of
people talking all at once
perhaps in a busy restaurant or a dinner
party maybe you are firmly engaged in a
conversation with somebody yourself when
all of a sudden from the noisy static of
the crowd around you your brain picks
out a single word or sentence and you
can hear it as clear as day even from
the other side of the room it could be
your name or a bit of gossip about
somebody that you know what just
happened was that your brains reticular
activating system ras activated at all
times there are literally millions of
bits of data in your surroundings noises
smells sites and physical sensations
this is far too much for your little
brain to comprehend multiple tests over
the years have shown that our brains are
only capable of focusing on a maximum of
four different things at once
and even that is optimistic most of the
time we focus on one to two things
simultaneously so how does our brain
decide that which of the potentially
millions of possible things to focus on
our worth our current time and attention
well it employs a conductor sitting in a
central base of the brain the brains
doorway to sensory inputs it acts like a
filter all the information around us is
constantly knocking on the door of our
brain for further processing
it is a job of the RAS to decide what to
let in when we put pen to paper the RAS
is activated because writing requires
fine motor control and the majority of
our focus so our Ras can't help but
prioritize whatever we are currently
writing about as the most important
processing job for our brain conversely
when text is typed every keystroke is
exactly the same there is no difference
in motor control between pressing the G
key to the a key on a keyboard once per
fish
our brains can type almost autonomously
without much conscious force at all and
so the RAS can just filter out a lot of
the information that we are taking in
whilst typing a luxury that it just
doesn't have whilst handwriting a 2010
study confirmed this with children when
they were asked to write words such as
spaceship by hands the areas of the
brain associated with learning lit up
when they typed the same words their
brain activity was a lot quieter as
though someone had turned off the lights
now put yourself in the hypothetical
scenario of viewing a university lecture
and you must take notes so you can learn
vital knowledge for an upcoming exam you
have a choice of either using a laptop
or a simple notepad and pen to recall
your notes which would you choose if you
chose a laptop then you are likely to do
much worse on the exam as researchers
Pam Muller from Princeton and Daniel
Oppenheimer from California University
found out in a 2014 study a group of
students were asked to watch five TED
Talks in a lecture hall and take notes
on them half of the students were given
laptops with no internet connection to
prevent some online distractions and the
other half were only given a pen and
paper after a 30-minute break both
groups were given a series of questions
to answer based on the TED Talks they
had just watched and taken notes on the
students who took longhand notes perform
significantly better at answering the
questions than the laptop note takers
Muller and Oppenheimer think that this
is because when we typed notes we
usually copy whatever the lecturer is
saying verbatim without attempting to
summarize it at all however because
handwriting is too slow to write down
every single word being spoken we are
forced to summarize two lectures main
points in doing so the brain spends much
longer processing the information that
it is taking in
Muller and Oppenheimer refer to this
process as encoding conversely when we
type the lecture notes word-for-word we
are using the laptop as external storage
for our brain sure we are hearing and
recording every word with keystrokes but
because this semi-automatic process
requires little actual thought or
contemplation our brain is not actually
processing encoding the information it
is merely and drink for our ears passing
straight through our brains and into our
fingertips
however when notes are handwritten
because we must think about the meaning
of what is being said in order to
summarize it in a very short amount of
time a significantly higher amount of
neural processing or encoding is
required and so even though we are
taking fewer notes overall we remember
the notes that we have written far far
better than when we typed them
furthermore you are more likely to
understand the meaning behind those
notes afterwards instead of staring
blankly at the five thousand word
document on your computer screen and
wanting to hammer your head into the
keyboard as you suddenly realize that
you have no idea what any of it means
interestingly they repeated the study
once more but this time allowed both
groups to reread and study their notes
for some time after the lectures it
would make sense that if the laptop note
takers could revise their word-for-word
nose then after doing so they would be
able to remember much more of it but
astonishingly this made little
difference on their learning the
longhand note takers still did much
better it seems that the encoding
process that the longhand note-takers
did when they first heard the
information was invaluable for their
long-term retention and understanding
but to me there is one overwhelming
reason that we should fight to keep
handwriting alive because it can be
absolutely beautiful calligraphy is an
for and all those who practice it desire
to reach such a level of mastery that
they are invited to an exclusive Society
with a really cool and memorable name
the International Association of Master
Penman and grocers and teachers of
handwriting it may not be such a pretty
name but my god does it have a pretty
logo
I am peph as it is commonly shortened to
are an international organization
responsible for choosing master Penman a
master Penman is a calligrapher who has
reached a distinguished level of mastery
in calligraphic arts there are many
stages to qualify as a master Penman
but the final is that they must rather
aptly create their own certificate there
are currently only 12 master Penman in
the world and they create beautiful
works of art like these
[Applause]
technology is amazing and if we all
abandoned it for the pen then the modern
world would have grind to a halt
but I think it's really important that
the art form of writing by hand is kept
alive as we rush ceaselessly into a
technological future IMF is certainly
grasping to keep the art of penmanship
and all its history and culture well and
alive but twelve master Penman can only
do so much if we all just took a moment
now and then to simply pen a letter to a
friend or if you're feeling more
adventurous try your hand at calligraphy
then collectively we can preserve the
very thing that built our world writing
I believe that the best way to get
started with calligraphy is by joining
Skillshare Skillshare is an online
learning community with thousands of
classes in writing art and calligraphy
premium membership gives you unlimited
access to high-quality classes on must
know topics so you can improve your
skills unlock new opportunities and just
do the work you love there are literally
hundreds of amazing calligraphy courses
on Skillshare for you to get stuck into
but personally I recommend you start off
with pen and ink calligraphy the art of
the envelope compared to the competition
skill sure is really affordable an
annual subscription is less than ten
dollars a month
and since Skillshare is sponsoring this
video the first 500 people to use the
promo link in a description will get
their first two months for free to try
it out completely risk-free thanks for
watching and thanks again for Skillshare
for sponsoring this video be sure to
click the link in the description if you
want to start your journey to becoming a
master Penman